bonsoir bonsoir alors nouvelle hausse
importante stéfane marion de 75 points
de base aujourd'hui la banque du canada
est ce que c'était justifié selon vous
oui mais ça commence à faire beaucoup
300 points de base en peine six mois
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma carrière donc
clairement on applique les faits de
façon brusque ça va laisser des traces
c'est à dire
on voit déjà certains certains secteurs
de l'économie qui ralentissent ou part
du secteur immobilier
il ya fort à parier qu'avec des hausses
supplémentaires qui ont été annoncés
aujourd'hui
il y aura un ralentissement économique
qui pourrait aussi
à costil auprès du consommateur au cours
des prochains mois donc c'est voulu on
veut ramener un rythme de croissance
plus faible dans les prochains
trimestres et je pense que c'est en
train de se concrétiser la bonne
nouvelle ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'on
est en train de devant céléos de tous
c'est comme si on avait rattrapé toutes
les hausses de taux qu'on avait refusé
de faire en 2020 dieu pour les faits
tout en 2022 je pense qu'après après le
monde octobre on pourra prendre une
pause monsieur fillon est ce la bonne
décision donc la banque dit quand même
aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas terminé que
la demande reste eurobus que d'autres
euros seront nécessaires mais vous vous
dites 26 octobre ya une grosse pression
on arrête
s'il donne et collabore avec notre
vision des choses est que l'inflation
continue de ralentir parce que ce qui
est inusitée cette fois ci c'est que on
y va avec des hausses très costaude au
niveau des taux d'intérêt notre contexte
où l'inflation semble se stabiliser en
la banque du canada
préconisent une médecine petit peu plus
plus douloureuse à savoir que je dois
voir confirmer que l'inflation pourrait
fortement diminuer d'ici la fin de
l'année si comme on pense l'inflation
étant de 7 5% en début de 1023 bon vieux
fort à parier que déjà cet automne avant
l'élection est ce qu'on s'en va se le
dise il en est à 3,25 pour cent est ce
qu'on s'en va 4%
je pense qu'on va tenter d'aller plus
près de 4% monsieur fillon mme may
3,75 juste en dessous car pour ça et
peut-être un objectif plus loin pour la
part du canada je m'explique il faut pas
oublier que la banque ne donnait pas la
seule à monter les taux ça se produit
partout à travers le monde la banque
centrale européen du soir européenne
d'en faire une demain la réserve
fédérale en faveur si tout le monde mais
les frais en même temps mais l'économie
mondiale vont évidemment ralentir plus
rapide est ce qu'on prend pour alliés à
la banque centrale pensez vous qu'au
début 2023 il y une récession au canada
je ne pense pas parce que dans un
contexte où l'économie mais tient quand
même un certain moment tom il ya quand
même des restants de stimuli budgétaires
qui sont re div qui sont déployés encore
dans l'économie canadienne nous on mise
plutôt sur une croissance autour de 1 %
ce qui est produit négatif c'est une
croissance oui bien moins douloureuse
que trois pour ça mais le 1 % garanti
aussi nous aident à penser que des gens
2023 il peut avoir un recalibrage la
banque du canada avec un ajustement à la
baisse des taux donc on est en train de
pointer rapidement directoire restrictif
de façon pouvoir calibri en 2028 equifax
rapportait cette semaine que les
canadiens sans d'être rapidement quand
même que les dépenses sur les cartes de
crédit que des soldes de cartes de
crédit augmente rapidement on a vu aussi
récemment des dossiers d'insolvabilité
qui se multiplient est ce que est ce que
pas un danger réel d'avoir une hausse de
taux qui est trop dommageable pour
beaucoup de ménages
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est en
haut un peu plus troubles à partir de
maintenant du moment qu'on dépasse 2 3%
3 raid 5 les prochaines actions d'abord
du canada pour être un petit peu plus
douloureuse moi je veux quand même faire
le point sur le fait qu' on est en train
de normaliser les faillites des ménages
qui avaient fortement baissé pendant la
pandémie donc je pense à gré à bhl mais
on parle d'une normalisation de ses
stocks et si cette normalisation et
s'effectue bas il ya en moyenne pour la
peinture de calibre et sans avenir un
ralentissement plus douloureux ou une
contraction du coni est ce que la banque
a raison de dire ok on a vu les sens
ralentir mais tout le reste des des
services est en hausse à ce que la
banque du canada à raison de deux 2
ciblé
cet état de fait présentement de fait
qu'il ya de l'inflation à peu près
partout même si l'essence commence à
ralentir
l'inflation sur une base année sur année
il est encore haute charente avec ing
lui la corde cela interdit au cours des
prochains mois pour avoir une
décélération déflation beaucoup plus
important qu'il ne pense dans notre cas
nous on pense que au niveau des biens de
consommation ils pourraient avoir
certaines baisses de prix et ces baisses
de prix là d'un secteur qui est bien
pour eux se traduit par une inflation
globale qui dessert beaucoup plus
rapidement
quand la banque indique que la forte et
qu une forte inflation qui risque de
s'en rappeler ça veut dire quoi ça
parle on pense que ça pourrait amener à
des anticipations croissance des
salaires qu'ils soient ou de l'aude la
productivité qui amènerait un
environnement d'inflation
beaucoup plus étendue comme on l'a vu
dans les années 70 je veux tout ceux de
vous rassurer monsieur fillion les
attentes de marché ne sont pas définies
à cet effet là les marchés croient
encore à la crédibilité de la banque
centrale
avec une intense avec une inflation des
attentes d'inflation autour de deux demi
pour cent au cours des prochaines années
stéfane marion merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir c'est très clair
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh